good morning John it's Tuesday February
17th and I've got some business to take
care of
first I must give away this signed copy
of my CD to the person who told the vets
the vast joke in the comments of the 51
jokes video the first 2,000 or so
contains some pretty excellent
candidates for example a rubberband
pistol was confiscated during algebra
class it was a weapon of mass disruption
did you know that Michael Jordan can
actually jump higher than your house uh
yeah my house can't jump at all but
before I make this video into 52 jokes I
should probably just tell you the winner
today I changed a light bulb cross the
street and walked into a bar it was then
that I realized my life is a joke I've
just been reading somebody jokes that I
was ready to accept one that challenged
the archetype of jokes and so I am
pleased to award that person surah zero
zero zero 1 1 1 a signed copy of my CD
check your youtube messages surah bar 2
I'm dealing with a lampshade on your
head the title of the anglerfish song
this has been a very difficult decision
for me ok I'm realizing that this wasn't
going to be a very interesting video so
I'm gonna put on every shirt that I own
I've got one more and this one is stuck
so now I know what it feels like for you
to try and put on a medium shirt this my
friends is the one that I must go with
from refugee John the anglerfish song
regarding the human mentality in respect
to how to interpret perpetually felt
emotions while educating you on the
subject of anglerfish that is a
nerdfighteria man and with all respect
to refugee Jonna I think we'll probably
all just call it the anglerfish song but
that will be its full title
congratulations refugee John last but
certainly not least John I would like to
announce the creation of the Ning
masters strengthening masters have been
selected and in no particular order
we're starting with Tom who screen name
is actually Tom Tom will be our images
ending master he'll go through all the
images submitted to the Bing promote the
good ones and then every Thursday he'll
have a post in which he talks about the
best images of the week next we have
amber the amber e1 amber the amber e1
will be in charge of two things one
organizing the forum and - she will be
head of nerdfighter projects so every
week on Monday she will feature the best
videos from nerdfighters on the Ning and
then we have Katie monster Katy monster
will be one the chat moderator and to
submitting whatever she wants to on
wednesdays next we have Eric of Eric's
every new day who will be Tuesday's
content promoter it's really hot in here
now we come to our books editor Sarah
slash Maddie's grace Saren is an English
teacher and very active mayor and Sarah
will be promoting book reviews and also
help us organize the nerdfighter
blurring book club which we have
completely neglected gee we'll be doing
that on Fridays and finally we have
three forum moderators first we have
penny penny is an experienced moderator
she is a supermodel a gigantic zelda
forum I can't say that there's any
better qualification for being a nerd
fighting Ning master than super modding
on a Zelda forum second we have Jenna
fighter by which I need Jennifer
Jennifer interesting who actually has
the license plate that says nerd fighter
on it and lastly we have chip who was in
my pants pretty much from the day they
were created those four murderers will
feature form content on Saturday and
Sunday so everybody could know all
awesome things that are going on
forum and finally a very special Ming
master the only Ming master who applied
who had a banana suit that's right Benny
booboo has a banana suit and he will do
whatever we ask him to while wearing the
banana suit please leave in the comments
anything you would like
Benny booboo to do with his banana suit
need to write a song about that but
things buddy Boober will do with his
banana suit all the things all the
things what do they include Oldman knee
booboo with your banana suit each of
these ding master positions are 3-month
positions at the end of that three
months people will be rotated in and
depending on various circumstances no
way am i vide you none and me I will see
me tomorrow